moved by the requests of former comrades
i have related in careful and orderly
fashion the illustrious deeds of the
franks in honor of the savior
when at the command of god they made an
armored pilgrimage to jerusalem
in homely style yet nevertheless truly i
have recounted what i deemed worthy to
be committed to memory and i have told
it as well as i can and just as i saw it
myself
although i do not dare to put this work
of the franks that i have mentioned on
inequality with the distinguished
achievements of the people of israel in
what way indeed do these franks differ
from the israelites and the maccabees in
those lands by my very side i have seen
them dismembered crucified flayed shot
with arrows butchered or killed by other
kinds of martyrdom for the love of
christ
or i have heard of it when i was far
away and yet they could be overcome
neither by threats nor blandishments
nay even if the slayer's sword had come
many of us would not have refused to
perish for the love of christ
oh how many thousands of martyrs died a
happy death on this expedition
in the year of our lord 1095
in the reign of the so-called emperor
henry in germany and king philip in
france throughout europe evils of all
kinds waxed strong because of
vacillating faith
pope urban then ruled in the city of
rome but the devil who always desires
man's destruction and goes about like a
raging lion seeking whom he may devour
stirred up to the confusion of people of
certain rival to urban wybert by name
what wonder that the whole world was a
prey to disturbance and confusion for
when the roman church which is the
source of correction for all
christianity is troubled by any disorder
the sorrow is communicated from the
nerves of the head to the members
subject to it and these suffer
sympathetically
when he heard too that interior parts of
romania were held oppressed by the turks
and the christians were subjected to
destructive and savage attacks he was
moved by compassionate pity
so urban a man prudent and revered
conceived a work by which later the
whole universe prospered
for he restored peace and re-established
the rights of the church in their
pristine condition and with a lively
determination he also made an effort to
drive out the pagans from the christian
lands
therefore since he endeavoured in every
way to glorify everything which was
god's
almost all voluntarily submitted
themselves to his paternal direction
and so
i felsher of shatra went with the other
pilgrims and for the benefit of
posterity i have carefully and
diligently stored all this in my memory
just as i witnessed it
[Music]
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
question what's the largest castle in
the world is it a windsor castle in
england b malball castle in poland or c
himeji castle in japan yes that's right
it's malbork castle thus proving that if
an englishman's home is his castle then
the polishman's home
is a very big castle and so a great
recommendation from magellan's
collection this week is knights 4k in
which you can discover more about these
supposedly chivalrous warriors and their
lovely big stone houses magellan tv have
supported this channel for more than a
year and they're a great choice if you
like documentaries they have more than
three thousand works to choose from and
you can now take advantage of an
exclusive offer 30 off an annual
membership this gives you an entire year
for less than 3.50 a month you can
simply click on the link in the
description to claim your discounted
membership today
thanks
we west franks traversed gaul and
travelling through italy came to lucha a
far-famed city
near there we met pope urban robert the
norman and stephen count of bloir talked
with him and others who wish likewise
having received his blessing we joyfully
advanced to rome many who had come thus
far with us waited no longer but at once
with disgraceful cowardice returned to
their homes
we however reached bari a rich seaport
town there we addressed our supplicants
to god in the church of saint nicholas
then coming to port we decided to cross
at once but because we lacked semen and
because fortune might play us false and
because furthermore it was wintertime
which exposed us to dangers robert count
of normandy was obliged to withdraw into
calabria and there he spent the whole
winter season
then many of the crusaders abandoned by
their leaders and fearing future want
sold their weapons there and taking up
against their pilgrim staves
ignominiously
returned to their homes
this desertion debased them before god
and man and it redounded to their shame
oh what a great and beautiful city is
constantinople
how many churches and palaces it
contains fashioned with wonderful skill
how many wonderful things may be seen
even in the streets or courts it would
be too tedious to enumerate what wealth
there is there of every kind of gold of
silver of every kind of robes and of
holy relics
after we were sufficiently rested our
leaders having taken council made
underoath a treaty with the emperor at
his own instigation when this had been
accomplished we crossed the sea which is
called the arm of saint george and
hastened then to the city of nicaea
it was then in possession of turks from
the east a valiant race of very expert
archers
these indeed had crossed the euphrates
river from persia 50 years before and
had subjected themselves to the whole
land of romania as far as the city of
nicomedia oh how many severed heads and
bones of the dead we then found lying
upon the plains near the sea
these people inexperienced in the use of
the arrow the turks had annihilated
moved by pity at this site
we shed many tears
and it was in the first week in june
that we came
last of all
to the
siege one army was formed of the many
which those skillful in numbers
estimated to be six hundred thousand
strong of these one hundred thousand
were armed for battle with leather
corsets and helmets if all who had
departed from their homes on the pious
journey had been present there without a
doubt there would have been six million
soldiers
but at rome in hungary and dalmatia some
unwilling to undergo hardships returned
to their homes in many different places
thousands were killed and some who went
with us fell sick and died
many graveyards were to be seen along
the roads on the plains in the places
where our pilgrims were buried
our leaders ordered machines of war to
be made rams scrapers wooden towers and
slings arrows were shot from the bows
and destructive stones were hurled
our enemies fired at us and we at them
each doing his best in these encounters
turks often perished struck by arrows or
stones and franks likewise truly you
would have grieved and sobbed in pity
for when they slew one of our men before
the wall in any way they let down iron
hooks by means of ropes and took the
body up
they snatched it away and none of us
dared or was able to wrestle it from
them
after stripping the corpse they threw
the body outside
with our machines we often assailed the
city but because a strong wall resisted
us the attack
failed
[Music]
we left nicaea on the third day and
advancing we came into the interior
parts of romania but when we had been on
the way for two days it was reported to
us that the turks had set ambushes for
us and expected to join battle with us
in the plains through which they thought
we were going to pass we did not lose
courage however at this news on that
night we had our tents protected on all
sides by guards
but early in the morning we took up our
arms and at the signal of the trumpet we
divided into wings with tribunes and
centurions leading the cohorts in
centuries then with flags flying we went
out against the enemy in good order
at the second hour of the day behold
their advanced guards approached our
scouts
when we had heard this we pitched our
tents near a certain marsh and took off
our pack saddles so that we would be
better able to fight when this was done
the emir and chief of the turks solomon
who had held in his possession the city
of nicaea and romania gathered together
about him the turks and pagan persians
who after a journey of 30 days at his
command had come to his aid
altogether they numbered 360
000 fighters all on horses and armed
with bows as was their custom we on the
other hand had both foot soldiers and
knights
but at that time duke godfrey and count
raymond and hugh the great had been two
days absent from us
therefore an irreparable loss resulted
as much from the number of our soldiers
who were killed as from our failure to
kill or capture the turks and because
those absent leaders received our
messengers late they were therefore late
in coming to our aid
the turks crept up howling loudly and
shooting a shower of arrows
stunned and almost dead with many
wounded we immediately fled and it was
no wonder for such warfare was new to us
all
already from another part of the marsh a
large column of them rushed violently up
to our tents and entering them snatched
our possessions and killed our people
what further shall i say we were all
huddled together like sheep shot in a
pen trembling and frightened surrounded
on all sides by enemies the air was
lashed with a great outcry from men
women and children as well as from the
pagans who rushed upon us
now there was no hope of life left to us
many fearing the death was near ran to
the priests and confessed to their sins
weeping they sang and singing
they wept
then by the disposition of god the
advance guard of hugh the great and
count raymond and duke godfrey came from
the rear upon this unhappy scene
from the very first hour of the day
until the sixth as i have said
difficulties checked us
but then
little by little we recovered and were
reinforced by our allies
[Applause]
indeed we continued our journey quietly
one day suffering such extreme thirst
that many men and women died from its
torments whole troops of turks fleeing
before us sought refuge by scattering
throughout romania in these regions we
were very often in need of bread and
other foods for we found romania a land
which is good and very rich in all
products
thoroughly devastated and ravished by
the turks
truly one would not know whether to
laugh or cry from pity when many of our
men without pack mules since many of
theirs had already perished loaded sheep
goats hogs and dogs with their supplies
such as clothing and food and whatever
luggage was necessary for pilgrims and
knights with their armor sometimes even
mounted oxen and who had ever heard such
a mixture of languages in one army there
were franks flemish frisians ghouls
lotharingians bavarians normans angles
scots italians iberians bretons greeks
and armenians
if a breton questioned me i would not
know how to answer either but though we
spoke diverse languages we were however
brothers in the love of god and seemed
to be nearest kin for if one lost any of
his possessions whoever found it kept it
carefully a long time until by inquiry
he found the loser and returned it to
him
[Music]
when our men and their horses who had
been wearied by much labor for many days
were refreshed by food and rest for four
months at antioch they resumed their
former strength
having arranged a plan one part of the
army went into in assyria desiring to
delay the march to jerusalem other
princes remained in the vicinity of
antioch
count raymond and his people seized
barra and mara by a courageous attack
after the former city had been captured
quickly and completely depopulated by
the slaughter of its citizens and
everything which they found there had
been seized they hastened to the other
city
here when the siege had lasted 20 days
our people suffered excessive hunger i
shudder to tell that many of our people
harassed by the madness of excessive
hunger cut pieces from the buttocks of
the saracens already dead there which
they cooked but when it was not yet
roasted enough by the fire they devoured
it with savage mouth
so the besiegers rather than the
besieged were tormented
meanwhile after they had made what
machines they could and move them to the
wall in an assault of great boldness
with god favoring the franks entered
over the top of the wall
and on that day and the following they
killed all the saracens from the
greatest to the least and plundered all
their substance
and so count raymond after tankred
joined him continued the journey to
jerusalem
the city of jerusalem is situated in a
mountainous region
lacking in streams woods and springs
here there is sufficient water sometimes
but occasionally the supply is reduced
by drawing off the water when the franks
viewed the city and saw it would be
difficult to take our princes ordered
wooden ladders be made
by erecting them against the wall they
hoped to scale it and by a fierce attack
enter the city with god helping
after they had done this when the
leaders gave the signal and the trumpets
sounded in morning's bright light of the
seventh day following they rushed upon
the city from all sides in an
astonishing attack
after consultation craftsmen were
ordered to make machines so that by
moving them to the walls they might with
god's aid obtain the desired end
so this was done after the machines were
prepared they again prepared to assail
the city early in the same morning when
they had gathered the machines and other
auxiliary weapons they very quickly
erected the tower in compact shape not
far from the wall after it was set up
and well covered by hides on the outside
by pushing it they slowly moved it
nearer the wall
then a few but brave soldiers at a
signal from the horn climbed on the
tower
nevertheless the saracens defended
themselves from those soldiers and with
slings hurled firebrands dipped in oil
and grease at the tower and at the
soldiers who were in it
thereafter death was present and sudden
for many on both sides
on the following day at the blast of the
trumpets they undertook the same work
more vigorously so that by hammering in
one place with the battering rams they
breached the wall
the franks entered the city
magnificently at the noon day hour on
friday the day of the week when christ
redeemed the whole world on the cross
with trumpets sounding and with
everything in an uproar exclaiming help
god they vigorously pushed into the city
and straight away raised the banner on
the top of the wall all the heathen
completely terrified changed their
boldness to swift flight through the
narrow streets of the quarters the more
quickly they fled
the more quickly they were put to flight
on the top of solomon's temple to which
they had climbed in fleeing many were
shot to death with arrows and cast down
headlong from the roof within this
temple about ten thousand were beheaded
if you had been there your feet would
have been stained up to the ankles with
the blood of the slain
what more shall i tell not one of them
was allowed to live
they did not spare the women and
children
after they had discovered the cleverness
of the saracens it was an extraordinary
thing to see our squires and poorer
people split the bellies of these dead
saracens so that they might pick out
coins from their intestines which they
had swallowed down their horrible
gullets while alive after several days
they made a great heap of their bodies
and burned them to ashes and in these
ashes they found the gold more easily
[Music]
oh time so longed for oh time remembered
among all others oh deed to be preferred
before all deeds
this was the place where the creator of
all creatures god made man in his
manifold mercy for the human race
brought the gift of spiritual rebirth
here he was born died and rose
cleansed from the contagion of the
heathen inhabiting it at one time or
another so long contaminated by their
superstition
it was restored to its former rank by
those believing and trusting in him
[Music]
you